on va démarrer par
delphine wespiser
delphine wespiser kiné la source de
cette pique have a à f in de spider à
chaque fois que benjamin temps aux
urinoirs ils aiment comparer la taille
de son attribut avec ses voisins c'est
vrai mais il est souvent déçu
et la première personne en date enfin du
moins celle que je sais c'est raymond
dont il a mis mal à l'aise et sont
comparés ensemble et tout et tout est-ce
que tu m'expliques il répond ce que
c'est vrai qu'ils soient oui c'est vrai
la cctv balles réelles
hamel tirs à balles réelles et bordel
dans deux minutes ton truc pareil alors
respect restons bien sûr nous en fait
moi je vais vous dire il a un problème
très grave elle nature 4x à ce qu'il est
parce que j'étais aux toilettes et il me
dit je rentre avec toi quand tu rentres
pas avec moi il n'ya qu'un toilettes
soit pas un traitement toilettes tu fais
et il pousse charrette de poussière il
pousse il ferme la porte on fait ce
qu'on ai je commence à taper vie parce
que le temps il est content et je
croyais qu'il allait attendre derrière
moi non et j'entends des gouttes d'eau
qui dit à une fuite je regarde là où il
n'y a pas de fuite il est en train de
pisser dans le lavabo nom et à des
problèmes cela alors il disant la bike
loger mais pis pas dans la vraie vie
c'est pas d'eau chaude qui me dit
est complètement tari les siens il
aurait pu partir mais bien sûr je vois
il arrive à côté moi je questionnais il
y fait voir
savoir où on en a le tout petit il se
barre
hier c'est vrai je sais
bien écoutez je te presser à des prêts
s'il n'y avait qu'un toilettes j'avais
très mes fractures et des
bâtiments plus libre non mais c'est vrai
la raison serait tellement plus libre et
sans déconner suis très léger tu sais je
vais tenir on a parlé de toi que mal et
c'est vrai j'étais quand c'était
avant-hier we pray et mathieu a eu cette
phrase formidable c'est que je t'ai
parlé des quatre femmes qui a dit non
mais quatre femmes dont il aurait eu
plus la dit quand on a eu quatre femmes
à et en cherche un homme mais bien sûr
mathieu
ont joué
couleur en plus qui rate et femmes
les séries et les vidéos on jan 2nd n'y
a rien a réagi me dit j'ai ma couleur
qui dégage un peu qu'est-ce que je peux
faire je fais fait un shampoing bleus
tombent l'on sera moins longue mais
voilà les conversations qu'on a il ya un
moment dire hey baby
g 17 pire en pire chaque jour c'est plus
bas mais on aimerait mathieu est ce que
vous pouvez s'il vous plaît à
récapituler on aurait dû être fait
aujourd'hui mais non il serait plus
libre et ce qu'il a fait voilà des
atouts ce qui fait qu'il est gay pardon
les regards
demande à son meilleur ami de jouer avec
sa guitare
couleurs ils rentrent de l'étoile de
raymond pouvoir sont ce n est pas du
tout je voudrais bien pire il me propose
une soirée grecque dans le marais au coq
avec des berges ces dessins
ici moment je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé pas la relève c'est tout hélas
aujourd'hui
disent inquiets
[Applaudissements]
les interventions comme un métronome
duguay
j'ai une idée
mais c'est pas moi voilà à mon avis va
vraiment devenir guide
je sais quoi vider ses collines et
badger l'elysée c'est justement pour
montrer que tu n'aies pour prouver qu'il
n'est pas gay mais j'ai pas besoin de
vous pour ça il me fascine nuit avec moi
[Applaudissements]
il ya deux mois
des rançons aussi entre matin
c'est vrai qu'à maman
moi je voudrais que les gens se sentent
bien sûr
liberté transition déconner dit sur
cbs que c'est pas le moment gay toujours
[Rires]
extrêmement mal et ça me fait des
avances pour la pub c'est un genre tels
sa wii malgré ces mises avait fait
maintenant tu m'excite comme ça à bon
escient
il m'a proposé un poste dans tpm people
en faisant des avances
des missions du harcèlement
voilà c'est ça son problème il faut
encore humoriste me crois qu'il a
c'est ça c'est ça son problème des voix
parfois tu sais ces saillies mais comme
avec son calme et des sorties de route
problème on est toujours mieux de le
recadrer voilà aller à cette première
vous qui est intéressant c'est trop bien
faire et à l'ats daniel moreau oulala je
suis gay
daniel moreau aurait reçu des tête de
corbeau couper dans sa boîte aux lettres
ainsi qu'une corde de pendu le colis
anonyme était signé des lettres et mbc
serait
matthieu delormeau
apparemment le master l'a mis là pour me
le dire il y avait une tête de cheval
même
film avec des miros j'imagine c'est ce
qui est arrivé à rodez n'est pas réparé
à temps est-ce que vous avez ça me fout
ça ben oui non j'ai eu un petit un petit
texto quand même voilà oui oui quand
même bon alors là oui ça oui isabelle va
revenir bientôt savez bien sûr
des textos quoi donne la teneur des
textes aux rebelles et à la 10 solide
arrêté de vieilles c'est pas sympa à
cette merde
bien lire et vous lui aurait répondu
quoi s'y perdre je préfère ne pas
répondre par la isabelle venise elle ne
va pas répondu cette [ __ ]
je leur ai dit allez on y va attention
guillaume genton entretenu une relation
intime avec une pétomane elle était
sublime aimé passer son temps à péter il
a dû mettre un terme à leur relation sur
que gilbert des dames c'est vrai c'est
castard
enfin
[Applaudissements]
elle était sublime avec des longs
cheveux et on a beaucoup parlé séverine
et elle était sonore ollier il a été non
non il m'a dit ma non mais on allume en
a parlé d'un coup c'est vrai ima il m'a
parlé de cette histoire donc je passe
qui dévoile les gens se confient à vous
oui bien sûr encore
tout balancer ils ont tort mais
ça il ya quelques années je sortais avec
une fille elle avait une particularité
en fait elle pétait quand elle était
très contente et un jour on est dans un
super resto et je me dire qu'elle était
très contente
et je les ai quittés après son nom c'est
vraiment ça c'est fou ça
c'est sa joie par le passé mais jamais
non mais voila voila merci c'est vrai
c'est une bonne émission
wrage attention revenant sur la lazio
fla
voilà c'est bien
saha
daniel moreau alors est ce vraiment
cinéma a des vues sur le producteur de
l'émission nourdine slimani elle a
déclaré on off maintenant que je suis
revenue autour de la table ça devait
être plus facile de me faire ken par
nourdine arrête et c'est une vraie info
on peut faire confiance à personne ah
bah non
merci alors à côté nous tous et c'est
vrai l'histoire est vraie je le sais ça
s'est passé dans les bureaux de la
production et du routage ni à personne
mais on peut vraiment être quasiment ça
n'existe pas les siens vous l'avez dit
dernier berger non parce que je le
croise ou le temps et voilà c'est gênant
pour lui
est-ce qu'on a une forte demande ce
qu'on a une photo de nourdine s'il vous
plaît photo de nordine slimani voilà on
va on va trouver la photo je précise que
c'est la bête qui est en moi qui parle
c'est un vrai fantasme sexuel c'est à la
chaîne alors no dig vient de me dire
qu'il a quitté le quartier
des musées dans mon oreille est ce que
voulaient voir nourdine
c'est
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'a t il aider son équipe d'un grand
jour j'imagine qu'il a plein de poils
sur le torse à
ccc mériterait de vision
du
monde il n arrive elle
arrive alors qu'est ce qui m'avait lâché
mardi à bâle écrivait le décrit d'abord
donc il a alors voilà c'est il fait très
mal va mal un mal
il fait beau il est bourru voyez
[Applaudissements]
c'est marqué sur son sweat voilà
voilà mais
non est ce que tu es heureux non dits
n'avait vu l'audi no dig est ce que tu
t'es la question est-ce que tu savais je
viens de l'apprendre et je suis assez
surpris vraiment
tu comptes qui était l'unique ans
dans pas longtemps du canada l'abandon
est vraiment vraiment je l'adorais l'afc
certaine personne n'a pour 2 voilà alors
il ya isabelle qui a envoyé les crs moi
en tout cas nourdine il m'a baisé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
enfin le troisième match
bodine alors heureux maintenant
alors est ce que vous êtes vous êtes
vous avez danse entre la cdc et surtout
des tcm et ados bisous graves sur la
bouche
ce donné quartier libre
c'est un barbu ça va être ma première
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on télévisuelle je
saurai m'en souvenir
merci en tout cas c'est vrai qu'il a il
a des poils ait tous ces problèmes et je
vais juste me donna même là rien
ces fruits d'un petit arbuste dans le
sang
c'est une agence a pris laniel aime les
barbots
la
méditerranée pourra-t-on chéri quand on
commence à escalader les montagnes on
démarre pas tout de suite parlé baisse
par à démarrer
sous peu ses droits puis par l'énergie
de plaies et donc on part et nourdine et
comme elle
est magnifique et à dos d'âne
doté des magnifiques il a un succès fou
il est marié à mince mais attention ça
va pas tous ses fidèles on l'a vu
malheureusement il est marié pas fidèle
mais marié
[Rires]
s'il a été acquise oula oula
benjamin castaldi la source et gilles
verdez
et c'est très grave
benjamin castaldi portera un lourd
secret de famille depuis quelques mois
il est important aujourd'hui de révéler
en direct dans tpm place secret alors
cyril je vais vous laisser diriger
si benjamin ce serait très bien que
benjamin c'est énorme c'est un scoop
c'est en fait ce que vous êtes en train
de lire c'est très bien qu'ils le disent
oui sinon vous allez le dire oui je vais
le balancer voilà donc voila comme tu
veux benjamin d'accord vie va changer je
le sais est ce que tu es prêt à
l'annoncer
quoi vous allez enlever votre poitrine
ah oui c'est énorme c'est non ah mais
oui elle était vraiment désolé partout
ouais bah oui bah ça vous allez à vue
là il est là il a une oreille
esprit ça concerne ma famille oui est-ce
que ça concerne mon grand fils oui
ajoute c'est we go cosmo cobayes
vaisselle et depuis depuis un moment
déjà enfin il a écopé vous êtes et lui
lui n'a rien dit il est bien tôt rien en
forêt voilà quoi et c'est une bonne
nouvelle c'est une bonne nouvelle
cette bonne nouvelle ouais c'est basique
puisque battu à lui mathieu 18
messieurs
félicitations à baja nakatani et c'est
pour ça qu'il a pris un coup de vieux
je n'ai
ni castaldi
voilà ça fait un beau surnom maintenant
pas pu accéder sans cette envie d'un
papy banshee bravo monde mérite ça va
arriver qu'on
ne connaît pas le sexe encore dit c'est
fou balle passera comme vous
personne
ne s'y attend pas que ça les robes
gagnent les chiens
merci oui ça a été très très lourd toit
de oui je suis très content je suis très
content pour toi benneteau susciterait
je repense aux trésoreries sont très
marion gravot c'est bon génial ça est
vrai benjamin castaldi grand père si on
m'avait dit ça
bah bravo benja franchement qui ça va
pas on finit quand même un petit coup
sur la tête par exemple ce moment un
petit peu
un petit peu sur les bannis quand même
grâce à lui je vois mon père a bien sûr
ils votent maryvette arrière grand père
est long mais robert j'imaginais ouais
là où c'est fou ça c'est fou quand il
vous est le grand père ivre alors il ya
pas john garang a pas d'usiné solaire de
son père mais qu'on est les codes du
grand père et grand père c'est fini
c'est fini foncé sur nous non mais c'est
à dire que dans notre tête ça toujours
grand père hier samedi on la vitre avec
du papier brossard
les gâteaux secs toi ça y est on n'a
même plus besoin d'avoir isabelle sayet
oui c'est nier alors oui ça y est il a
passé manier les balades en magma voilà
bravo c'est bien
ça vous n'êtes rien ça vous dégoûte un
peu non non pas du tout non non c'est
génial je suis très heureux pour vous
mais c'est vrai que voilà je sais que ça
vous amis quand même un vrai voilà c'est
normal non ça m'a ému et content mais
bon je suis quand même grand père
coiffure puces et votre fils va être
prêt tu vas avoir pratiquement le même
âge que le live ainsi aussi on le ferait
bizarre mais je sais le fils de castaldi
avec l âge maman fait-il assez grand
pour elle en fait longue parce que
s'arrête l'oncle 1,6 et sa mclaren donc
retenu celle de son fils elles ont le
même match alors qu'ils vont se balader
six mois le fils de castaldi l'a 16
voire même vers 16h des fleurs a failli
fait six mois
mais voilà donc mais oui sont donc va
avoir deux ans plus tard d'avoir une vie
de bâton de chaise forcément ben oui tu
en es là maintenant mon chou sylvain
dame à dire la cua bâton de chaise à ce
que je crains que le bâton ketchup dans
les
trucs et laisse peut-être